now Russia's foreign ministry has warned
that a change in the status of the Golan
Heights would violate United Nations
resolutions on the issue the warning is
a reaction to a tweet by US president
Donald Trump who said the Golan Heights
would become a recognized part of Israel
Israel annex the Golan from Syria in
1981 in a move not recognized
internationally Syria has condemned
Trump's declaration as irresponsible
standing by for us in Jerusalem is our
correspondent Tanya Kramer Tanya what
more can you tell us about reactions in
the region well of course these three
types caused more concern and also a lot
of criticism in neighboring countries
here in the region the Syrian state news
agency quoted a foreign ministry
officials saying that the Golan will
remain the Golan Heights always Syrian
Arab and that the regime would work to
recover it by all available means also
the Iranians have slammed the decision
calling it a move that was illegal and
unacceptable but of course in Israel the
move was widely welcomed as a kind of
consensus here that this is just a de
facto recognition of reality on the
ground and the Golan Heights are seen as
a strategic asset Israel is also in the
middle of a fierce election campaign and
all the main parties have called out or
called for a recognition there's been a
sense here that the Trump administration
is leaning towards such a move and when
the tweet was published prime ministers
Prime Minister Netanyahu's reaction was
very Swift he had been hosting US
Secretary of State Mike Pompeo here for
the past two days and this is what he
had to say
president Trump has just made history I
called him
I thanked him on behalf of the people of
Israel he did it again
first he have recognized Jerusalem as
Israel's capital and moved the u.s.
embassy then he pulled out of the
disastrous Iran treaty and we imposed
sanctions but now he did something of
equal historic importance he recognized
Israel's sovereignty over the Golan
Heights Oh Benjamin Netanyahu is clearly
pleased with Donald Trump's statement
there could donald trump's tweet end up
giving netanyahu a boost in the upcoming
elections well that's also being
discussed over here and some
commentators here see it as an election
gift to miss netanyahu
with the elections just being three
weeks away and mr. Netanyahu has also
waited to to meet with mr. Trump next
week in Washington of course all eyes
will be on that meeting whether this
tweet and will relate into translate
into actual policy some also here in
Israel said it might aim to deflect from
mr. Netanyahu's legal troubles because
some new allegations against him in
another corruption affair have surfaced
in recent days having said that there's
also the question what does it benefit
to Israel because the intended
recognition by the u.s. is of course a
major u.s. major policy shift of view as
policy here in in the region but is it
totally ignores again international law
it also ignores UN Security Council
relations resolutions and also most of
the international community would
consider the Golan Heights still as
occupied territory Tania thank you so
much for bringing us up-to-date DW Tanya
Kramer in Jerusalem